[Music]
on this monday night ontario's long-term
care
failure deflecting responsibility and
dodging questions and we have questions
from your floor minister
who is accountable after a scathing
report found critical decisions came too
late and care homes were ill-equipped
who is accountable in alberta canada's
worst covet hot spot
i sent multiple patients to the icu last
night as nova scotia's premier loses
patience
with rule breakers what is wrong with
you heard immunity isn't achievable
and if so how plus investigating sexual
misconduct in canada's military
the accusations of a cover-up
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
no one fully anticipated the extent of
the pandemic and the reach of the virus
but there is one thing experts have said
from the very beginning
speed trumps perfection and the greatest
error is not to act
fast and yet a detailed report from
ontario's long-term care commission
found
critical decisions came too late and the
government's emergency response system
proved inadequate to protect staff and
residents from covet 19.
the second wave in ontario was more
deadly than the first
and the iron ring premier ford promised
to put around long-term care homes
never happened more than 3 700 ontarians
died in long-term care that report was
released
late on friday night today the minister
of long-term care took
just three questions about it i'm
grateful
to the commission uh for what they have
uh
provided as a guide and uh we will move
forward
so appreciate everyone's interest thank
you
can you say a little longer there are
more reporters on the phone line and
this is a very important issue
any more time and we have questions from
your floor minister we have two
questions from the floor and we have
people on the line who like to ask more
questions
the minister did promise to do right by
the thousands of people and families who
have been impacted
travis danraj has our top story tonight
it was a simple question that strikes to
the heart of the tragedy outlined in
this 322-page report
the tragedy in long-term care when did
the minister find out that 26
residents 26 seniors with families were
found dead because of dehydration during
the first wave
this was merely fullerton's answer we
have to move forward
we have to move forward and i came to
politics
because of long-term care the neglect of
this sector
and i came to fix it looking forward may
be what the minister wants to do but it
is certainly not what long-term care
advocates have the stomach for monday
they are going to have to answer people
are dying they're still dying
julie farrell lost her mother she says
the minister the entire government is
accountable and the report's findings
must serve as a path to solutions
so more deaths don't happen we will not
tolerate this
these are our parents these are people
that built
our country and gave us the life that we
have
now and to treat them with such
disrespect is absolutely
terrible how convenient for you it is to
look forward instead of actually
providing clear answers and taking
accountability for the fact that you
were aware
that there was widespread negligence
leading to death because of
understaffing
dodging questions and deflection
continued in question period
the opposition pushing for fullerton's
resignation
they should have been taking over those
for-profit homes
but they didn't do any of that instead
what they did
was stop the inspections and then remove
any
uh legal liability from the private
for-profit
long-term care sector thank you speaker
and i think the magnitude of this
problem has been building for many many
years
indeed the commission's report did find
failures in ontario's long-term care
system which had been building for years
fullerton not willing to apologize for
the pc government's handling of that
system during kovid
the liberals would not either pointing
fingers back at the current government
no i i think i would apologize for not
doing more i mean we built or rebuilt 30
thousand beds
we raise the wages of psw's four dollars
an hour travis stan rash global news
after what has been a slight downward
slide in new coven cases in canada there
are signs that progress
is slowing according to dr teresa tam
canada's daily case count is still going
down but
not as fast as it was and the number of
people getting very sick and dying
is still rising in the last week the
number of coveted patients in intensive
care across canada rose by 12 percent
and an average of 50 deaths were
reported each day
the situation is most dire in alberta
right now more than 2 000
new cases were reported there today and
the test positivity rate is over
13 that's the highest since the pandemic
began
the province has had the most active
cases in canada per capita for weeks
today premier jason kenney said he is
working on a plan to implement more
public health measures
but as case counts climb he keeps
waiting
heather urix west reports
calgary's peter lockheed center has been
busy the hospital serves the city's
northeast
a quadrant full of essential workers who
have been hit hard by covid19
we had nine admissions to the to the
kova team
or or transfers in i sent
multiple patients to the icu last night
the volume of covet patients being seen
here has risen dramatically in the last
two weeks icu's are nearly full the way
things are going
we're going to continue to go up
alberta's former chief medical officer
of health says
time is running out with variants
fueling continued exponential growth in
the province
aggressive public health restrictions
need to come into effect now
we need to stop with these half measures
and go to something that actually brings
us under control
last week the province introduced some
new restrictions
though patios churches malls and hair
salons remain open
the premier also promised to get tough
on albertan's floating public health
restrictions
and then all weekend long this hundreds
gathering in central alberta
for a rodeo what we saw on the weekend
with this rodeo quite frankly
it's not something that just happened
out of the blue this is something
that that a seed that this premier has
been sowing
through his inconsistent weak leadership
over the last year the premier says he
was
angered and disturbed by the rodeo over
the weekend conceding monday afternoon
that current restrictions are not going
far enough
given the issues we saw this weekend and
the record high cases reported
we are developing a package of stronger
public health measures
which i expect to announce tomorrow i
feel angry i feel sad
dr fabro hopes the measures will be
strong enough to bend the curve
because he knows if they fail patients
will need to be triaged
and those decisions will fall to doctors
like him
i think that just that realization only
hit me a couple days ago and i think
that
um the closer we get to that the more
the more terrifying that prospect is
frustrating too
because after months of warnings this
wave
is not a surprise heather urex west
global news
calgary in nova scotia 146 new cases
were reported in the last 24 hours there
are now
943 active cases there and that is a new
record
the province is clearing up a backlog of
some 45 000
tests there is a bit of good news the
test positivity rate in nova scotia is
very low
just one percent but hospitals are
already reaching a critical point
as ross lord reports today the premier
took aim at people who aren't taking the
situation
seriously in a province that prides
itself on suppressing covet 19
a day-to-day pattern of new cases in the
triple digits is tough to swallow
we are not anywhere close to being out
of the woods hospitalizations have risen
into the dozens putting more strain on a
health care system that struggles to
keep up with demand
at the best of times nova scotians are
getting tested more often than other
canadians
overwhelming the province's ability to
process results
and forcing some people to wait long
periods of time to find out
if they're in the clear well i'm
diabetic
and i'm very like this you know high
risk
and i'd like to make sure that
everything's negative joyce mcdonald has
been waiting for a week for results that
normally come in two or three days
she has no covet 19 symptoms but is
housebound shouldering a nagging burden
i have my grandchildren that i
homesit every day while they do their
schoolwork
and i'm doing my work online but it's
just so important with all the children
around my daughter it's very important
to have this
test result as the race between vaccines
and variants continues
nova scotia police are finding lockdown
violators
up to two thousand dollars per person
but nova scotia's premier suggests
not everyone is getting the message i
have a serious question
what is wrong with you how come you
don't take this as serious as it you
should
the premier says the vast majority of
nova scotians are going along with
restrictions
raising hopes the number of new cases
could start declining
later this week ross lord global news
key to getting out of the crisis is
getting more canadians fully vaccinated
more doses are coming
in the next four weeks more than 9.1
million doses of pfizer and modern
vaccines are scheduled to be delivered
roughly 33 percent of canadians have
received at least one dose only
3 percent have been fully vaccinated
with both doses
there is still no timeline on the
distribution of the single shot johnson
johnson vaccine after health canada
flagged
potential quality control issues in the
u.s and there is mixed messaging on who
should get it the national advisory
council on immunization recommends
johnson and johnson for canadians
aged 30 and up but also says some people
might want to wait
for pfizer or moderna david aiken
reports
vaccination is essential to end the
coven
19 pandemic yes but which vaccine to get
politicians and most public health
officials have been saying the best
vaccine to get
is the one you're offered first but the
doctors on the national advisory
committee on immunization
known as nasi well they have a different
message what we've said
all along is that the mrna vaccines
are the preferred vaccine the mrna
vaccines are
pfizer biontech and moderna not
astrazeneca or johnson and johnson
individuals
need to have an informed
choice to be vaccinated with the first
vaccine that's available
or to wait for an mrna vaccine
but the implicit message from nasty to
delay getting one vaccine in favor of
another
is the last thing frontline emergency
room doctors want to hear
it's very frustrating to hear that
recommendation the recommendation
should be and has always been by
physicians on the ground to take the
first vaccine available to you
as soon as possible or public health
officials battling the pandemic
the bottom line is take whatever vaccine
you're offered
but for now the first johnson and
johnson vaccines
the first single dose vaccines approved
for use in canada
are held up a first shipment of three
hundred thousand doses arrived last week
but
health canada held them back over
concerns that an ingredient may have
been contaminated
during their manufacture at a plant in
baltimore maryland
it's it's certainly uh it's sort of
being held in freezers in good condition
and uh
until the obviously health canada does
its due diligence and uh
i can't give a timeline i would i would
leave that to health canada and so it
may be
pfizer biontech to the rescue 2 million
doses of that vaccine are arriving in
canada this week
and every week during the month of may
david aiken global news ottawa
the national advisory council on
immunizations has also issued new
guidance for pregnant women it's
recommending those who are pregnant get
vaccinated against covid19 but says
if the benefits outweigh the risks the
pfizer and modern vaccines are preferred
over astrazeneca because of the risk of
rare blood clots the city of iqaluit has
declared a state of emergency after a
surge in covet-19 cases
eight new infections were reported in
nunavut today all in the capital city
there are now 85 active cases in the
territory involving the b-117 variant
none of it is also suspending its travel
bubble with the northwest territories
because of rising case numbers
in yellowknife more than 100 million
americans nearly 40 percent of all
adults are now
fully vaccinated and the governors of
three u.s states including new york
say most public health restrictions will
soon be lifted
today is a milestone for new york state
and a significant
moment of transition
on may 19th new york new jersey and
connecticut plan to lift most covid 19
capacity restrictions based on a steady
decline
in the positive cobit 19 tests and
hospitalizations
restaurants retail offices arts and
entertainment venues and other services
will welcome back crowds new york city
plans to restore 24-hour subway service
on may
17th well nowhere in the world is seeing
a more devastating wave of covid19
than india 368 000 new infections were
reported there today
it is the 12th day in a row with daily
case counts
above 300 000.
death is everywhere more than 3 400
people are dying every day
shortages of life-saving medical oxygen
are leaving many patients
without any chance of survival oxygen
producing equipment is now coming in
from other countries
on sunday india's supreme court urged
national and state governments to
consider imposing
lockdown measures to limit the spread
and allow time to build up an emergency
supply
of oxygen nearly three months after the
federal government declared the proud
boys a terrorist entity the canadian
chapter of the group now says it has
officially dissolved in a statement
members of the far-right group claim
they were never terrorists or a white
supremacy organization
they say they were just regular
patriotic canadians
they claim they've run into financial
difficulties from trying to overturn the
government's terrorist designation
in february canada said the group posed
an active security threat
and played a pivotal role in january's
deadly attack on the u.s capitol
more than a dozen group members face
charges in connection
with that violence and there is some
personal news tonight about one of the
world's most powerful couples
bill and melinda gates have announced
they are getting divorced after 27 years
of marriage
the couple met at microsoft in 1987
married and raised three children in
2000 they created the non-profit bill
and melinda gates foundation which has
given billions to a range
of initiatives including global health
and alleviating poverty
in a statement on twitter the couple
said they will continue to work together
at the gates foundation but said
we no longer believe we can grow
together as a couple
in this next phase of our lives
the investigation into sexual misconduct
in canada's military
coming up why the federal liberals are
being accused
of a cover-up
the federal government is taking more
heat tonight over its handling of
allegations of sexual misconduct within
the military
the liberals are now being accused of a
cover-up after shutting down a house of
commons committee with no explanation
michael couture has been watching this
unfold
mike well donna the committee on
national defense has been working for
weeks on who knew what when it comes to
the allegations of sexual misconduct
against the former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance
it was supposed to meet today but that
meeting was abruptly cancelled
at the last minute they were supposed to
continue debating a motion
first brought up last week to call the
prime minister's chief of staff
katie telford as a witness the liberals
have offered
no explanation for canceling the meeting
except for this comment by the committee
chair
in question period that the defense
committee will be meeting at its normal
time this coming friday at one o'clock
still opposition members expect the
liberals to continue filibustering in
the committee to block attempts
to have telford testify well that's the
only logical conclusion that you can
draw is that they're afraid of what she
will reveal in any such testimony
prime minister justin trudeau has said
no one in his office knew the
allegations against vance
were a me too complaint but documents
obtained by global news
show bureaucrats labeled them
allegations of sexual harassment
vance has denied all allegations of
inappropriate behavior
opposition mps say shutting down the
committee is a continuation of a
cover-up by the liberals
and it's why the conservatives
introduced a motion that will be debated
on tuesday
to have telford turfed so she made a
decision
to either keep this from him or his
description
of his involvement isn't truthful
either one of those options is troubling
the ndp has said it will not support
that motion
saying the two people responsible for
how this was handled
our defense minister harjit sajin and
prime minister justin trudeau
donna all right michael couture in
ottawa thanks
a potential return to normal life still
ahead is herd immunity
achievable
herd immunity has long been thought to
be a golden ticket that will allow
restrictions to be lifted and life to
return to normal
but a growing number of epidemiologists
believe it is too tall in order and
likely not achievable eric sorenson
explains why more than half of american
adults have received at least one
vaccine dose but the vaccination rate is
falling
i do not plan on getting it unless i am
forced
vaccine hesitancy has slowed demand even
as covet variants require
a higher percentage to be vaccinated and
many experts now believe the us will not
reach herd immunity
now that we really understand the role
that these variants are playing
and and how much the the variants do
change the contagiousness of this virus
here
herd immunity has become elusive herd
immunity was the ultimate goal
to vaccinate our way entirely out of the
pandemic
canadian authorities say it's too early
to know what level of immunity
is possible here the emphasis is
shifting to reducing the number and
severity of cases
we could manage this through
vaccinations such that
this is something that affects people
at worst like a cold and uh
limits uh a severe illness
canadians are among the most willing
vaccine recipients in the world
two months ago an ipsos survey asked
whether people agreed if a vaccine for
covet 19 were available to
me i would get it in canada 79 agreed
a number that has risen more than 20
points since december
in the u.s only 65 percent agreed they
would get a vaccine
if available if we can get 90 or 95
vaccination we will be in a hugely
stronger position to go back to normal
life without seeing deaths and
hospitalizations
in the u.s big crowds without masks are
being allowed
and if the virus continues to percolate
more so there than in canada
questions around cross-border travel
will persist including the potential for
requiring vaccine passports
overall this country may be in a better
position to manage the virus
we'll probably be somewhere between
control and elimination
going forward this is not over by a long
shot
it's just that the acute crisis phase is
probably over sometime this year
renting the long term management phase
management that will include vaccines
and booster shots in the months and
years ahead eric sorensen global news
toronto
next marking five years since the fort
mcmurray fires
anyone who lived through the wildfire in
fort mcmurray alberta knows what day
this is
five years ago a ferocious fire
nicknamed the beast
ripped through town this is fort
mcmurray birding
we were live that night as a wall of
flames leapt into town almost 90 000
people the entire population of fort
mcmurray had to flee
making a terrifying drive on the only
road out
police say the fire was human caused but
they don't know
if it was arson more than 80 percent of
the community has since been rebuilt but
boy those memories linger that is global
national for this monday
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye